[Applaus]
wir alle haben wir die Möglichkeit, mr zu senden
.  DeSantis und vermisse den Truck die
Botschaft Ich bin sehr besorgt über die
hasserfüllte Rhetorik Die Lügen und
Täuschungen einer Regierung in der GOP Ich
komme als Mutter heraus und will eine bessere Zukunft Eine
respektvolle Widerlegung unserer Differenzen Wir
brauchen keine Lügen und und hassen uns  brauchen eine
Gemeinschaft, die voller Respekt
und Liebe ist, und deshalb bin ich hier
, um einem der größten
Präsidenten, den wir je hatten, auch hier im
Namen von Andrew Gilliam zuzuhören, um die
Leute zu ermutigen, für ihn zu stimmen
[Applaus  ]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Republikaner sind in Florida gewarnt und
wir müssen sicherstellen, dass sie
für die Menschen der Menschen blau werden und
über die Menschen, die wir blau wählen müssen,
müssen wir für Sie stimmen  Holen Sie sich unseren
Staat zurück,
warum, weil alles wichtig ist,
Gesundheit, unsere Umwelt, unser grundlegendes Menschenrecht,
wenn die Republikaner die
Wahlen wieder stehlen, wird es in
Florida weitergehen, es spaltet uns, es ist Rassismus,
es ist Korruption, es ist eine ganze Menge
Dinge, die die Peo  Viele haben es
satt, deshalb sehen Sie das
so groß wie jeder aus
Südflorida, der wegen dieser Veranstaltung hier war.